welcome back to the David show
for Sarah Huckabee Sanders.
She's upset that people are calling her a
liar and she also can't seem to stop lying
recently saying that Donald Trump reads more
than anyone she knows.
The only way that's true is if no one she
knows reads at all.
I, I've talked before about this issue of
what I think is a really unfortunate rehabilitation
of people's image that will happen after they
leave the Trump administration or even after
they simply are out of power.
George W. Bush being an example of this and
one example under the Trump administration
is former Trump's first former press secretary
Sean Spicer, who is now seen much more positively
nationally after participating in that reality
show, dancing with the stars and no longer
being Donald Trump's daily liar in chief.
And this is sad because you know, it's not
about grudges or anything like that, but when
people are hugely bad actors who perpetuate
a disastrous agenda, run interference for
it, defend a nightmarish president and truly
bad acts by that president, they shouldn't
be, uh, immediately seen.
As funny, great people because they no longer
work for the president of the United States.
This brings us to Donald Trump's second former
press secretary, Sarah Huckabee Sanders, who
as I've been saying since the beginning, is
really one of the most vile characters from
the entire nightmare that has been the Trump
administration.
She doesn't like being called a liar.
She recently said to the New York times, quote,
I was attacked for everything, not just my
performance.
I was called a fat soccer mom.
My kids were threatened.
My life was threatened.
It was a lot.
I hate harping on it, but to be in the position
I'm in and to have secret service, that's
not normal.
I don't like being called a liar.
The other stuff has bothered me far less.
Well, one way not to be called a liar would
be to stop lying constantly.
She did an interview on Fox news Sunday night.
She said both that she is upset people call,
call her a liar, and told the obvious, blatant,
brazen, bold face lie that Donald Trump reads
more than anyone that she knows.
Now, of course, it's widely known that Trump
doesn't read.
There is not a single book that Donald Trump
even claims to have read in the last 30 years,
other than I guess his own book, art of the
deal, which I doubt he actually read, uh,
and the Bible, which he definitely didn't
read and mentioned only to appeal to evangelical
voters during his campaign.
So let's go to the video.
Check out what Sarah Huckabee Sanders said
in this total softball.
Pathetic excuse for an interview for which
interviewer Steve Hilton should be ashamed,
but I'm sure he's not.
Take a look.
I mean, I've watched this process play out
so many times, set in hundreds of meetings
with the president, and the idea that he can
only take in one or two bullets is absurd.
I've watched him consume massive amounts of
information processing point.
They go, Oh, he doesn't read briefings and
whatever.
How does he reads more than anybody?
I know every single foreign trip.
We actually would laugh about the fact he
has boxes upon boxes, file boxes where he
reads for hours.
The rest of us want to take a break.
We want to sleep and the president works the
entire time.
He will spend hours on the plane reading through
notes, reading through newspapers, magazines.
He consumes a massive amount of information
constantly.
At the end, she sort of hints at the truth,
which is he's not reading.
She mentions magazines.
He's haphazardly paging through magazines,
probably looking for pictures of himself and
headlines that's not reading Sarah.
I hate to break it to you maybe where she
comes from or how she was raised.
That counts as reading, but that's not reading
in any real sense of the word.
Meanwhile, she's upset that people call her
a liar regularly.
You're lying all the time.
The reason she's called a liar is that she
lies constantly, but not even in ways that
are believable in ways that are completely
obviously untrue lies about something less
well documented or that are less.
Obviously a lie maybe could get by, but when
you're lying about something that is so widespread
right there, there's widespread reporting
about how AIDS had to reduce Donald Trump's
briefing to a few bullet points with a picture
or a graph or a map or to Trump when he was
presented with lots of texts to read, would
yell and get angry about handing documents
once reportedly saying, these are just words,
a bunch of words.
It doesn't mean anything.
And throwing the papers back on the table
in front of him, if you're reading, you don't
refer to reading material as just words.
That's not something that voracious readers
tend to do.
And let's even go further.
Trump only seems semi-literate literate.
He seems, uh, we've done deep dives into this
and he has limited reading ability.
This is not saying that he is illiterate.
What I'm talking about is when you don't read
for decades, and we know he doesn't use computers,
he would negotiate deals on the phones.
He hasn't, there's no books that we can say
with certitude that Donald Trump has read
when you don't read for decades.
And by that I mean you sit down with at least
semi dense material.
You go through it sequentially building your
knowledge of the material and integrating
it, assimilating it into your preexisting
knowledge.
You lose that ability.
There's no, this isn't even special about
Donald Trump.
There's no way that the brain can maintain
its ability to assimilate complex information,
the kind that a president would consume under
normal circumstances if you don't do it for
decades.
And remember that Donald Trump's co-writer
of art of the deal, really the writer Trump
told them stories and he wrote the book.
He said the entire time that he worked on
the book with Donald Trump, he never, Donald
Trump pickup a single book.
He didn't see a book anywhere around Donald
Trump.
There's this report of Trump keeping a book
of, I think it was Hitler's speeches on his,
uh, a bedside table.
Who knows if he even actually read it.
I would be shocked if he did.
If Sarah Huckabee Sanders wants to stop being
called a liar, stop telling obvious brazen,
demonstrable lies.
And the allegations about lying all the time
would stop pretty quickly.